god hard deuxième
ce sont des mauvais la première fois
c'est la télé
difficile dans le cinéma c'est qu'à une
énorme somme d'argent investi dans un
temps assez court et qu'on a pas le
droit de se tromper en principe comme si
on a fait un mauvais plan on peut
recommencer une fois on peut pas
recommencer 50 fois et encore si c'est
un plan très compliqué avec deux cents
figurants avec greta garbo ou marilyn
monroe bas semblent pas recommencer si
les ratés il est raté or ce que je
voudrais pas ce que je voulais me
permettre c'est le sait leur ratage au
contraire pour garder le ce que
j'estimais le meilleur et de me
permettre si je tourne un film en en un
mois deux ratés de rater des choses
pendant 29 jours s'il faut et pendant le
30e tourner tout ce qui est bon on ne
fait pas un gros plan avec un avec un
petit avec un grand angulaire bon ben on
va le faire on fait pas de travelling à
la main bon ben on va le faire et ça
correspondait à moi un désir de
2,2 faire que de montrer que tout était
permis puisque dans le cinéma français
c'était finalement un régime
d'inquisition et de cellules et de
compartimentage ou vraiment il fallait
où c'était là vraiment très difficile de
pénétrer avant 40 ans godard deuxième